bonjour et bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro de parlement hebdo l'émission qui
revient sur les temps forts de
l'actualité à l'assemblée nationale et
au sénat et que j'ai le plaisir de vous
présenter avec brigitte boucher bonjour
brigitte un jour tam et cette semaine
est riche elle est marquée par l'arrivée
du nouveau gouvernement castex au
parlement et pour commenter toute cette
actualité notre invité est aujourd'hui
stéphane peut vous êtes député
communiste de seine saint denis et c'est
brigitte qui vous présente
bonjour stéphane peut vous est né à
pauvres dans les pyrénées atlantiques un
certain 24 juillet mais c'est en
seine-saint-denis que vous officiez un
bastion historique du communisme votre
parti de coeur député touche à tout
membre de la commission des lois
on vous connaît surtout pour vos prises
de parole sur la défense de votre
territoire le plus pauvre de france ou
sur le logement
un secteur où vous avez pris votre élan
à l'assemblée élan pour évolution du
logement de l'aménagement et du
numérique
c'était le nom de la loi que vous avez
largement tenter d'amender alors votre
signe distinctif vous aimez cultivez
votre jardin
au sens propre comme au sens figuré chez
les communistes c'est forcément un
jardin partagé pour la collectivité mais
cultivez votre jardin ça vous permet
sûrement de garder la tête froide en
politique c'est quoi votre secret
d'essayer d'avoir en permanence le recul
alors cultiver son jardin c'est le sait
au sens propre
j'essaye de d'avoir de temps en temps je
pense avoir la main verte donc de temps
en temps je l'entretiens cette main
verte
et puis de prendre le recul de 2 de
continuer à lire d'essayer autant que
faire ce peu d'années en ce moment
c'était difficile d'aller au théâtre de
de prendre un peu le recul est de
toujours avoir la pensée pour les gens
conclut que l'on sert c'est à dire que
quand on est pris dans le tourbillon de
la vie parlementaire avoir une pensée
pour les gens de saint denis de
pierrefitte et de villetaneuse tous ces
visages que l'on croise ces courants
chez les parlementaires j'espère qu'on
est nombreux à le faire
en tout cas quand vous avez été comme
moi 25 ans élu local
forcément le nombre de visages que vous
avez
en tête est forcément très une très très
très nombreux on va parler en tout cas à
des nouveaux visages du gouvernement
cette semaine d'abord baptême du feu
pour le premier ministre et son nouveau
gouvernement à l'assemblée jean castex
et ses ministres ont répondu aux tirs
nourris des députés de l'opposition lors
des questions au gouvernement la
commission d' enquête sur la gestion de
la crise de lakovic 19 poursuit ses
auditions à l'assemblée cette semaine
martin hirsch a répondu aux attaques du
professeur out et on finira par le
rapport du sénat qui s'alarment d'un
risque de radicalisation islamiste et
qui propose 44 mesures pour lutter
contre cette menace qu'ils jugent
inquiétante
et pour commencer cette émission
première séance pour jean castex à
l'assemblée
[Musique]
jean castex et les nouveaux ministres
ont fait leurs premiers pas à
l'assemblée cette semaine une première
séance de questions au gouvernement où
l'opposition n'a pas retenu ses coups
elsa mandingue avant le baptême du feu
pour le premier ministre jean castex
dans l'arène de l'hémicycle je souhaite
la bienvenue dans notre hémicycle au
premier ministre et aux membres du
nouveau gouvernement
pour sa première séance de questions au
gouvernement
je voudrais d'abord vous dire toute
l'émotion et tout l'honneur que je
ressens m'exprimant aujourd'hui pour la
première fois devant vous voilà pour les
présentations
puis vient le vif du sujet monsieur le
premier ministre le président de la
république vous a confié je le cite la
responsabilité de tracer un nouveau
chemin pour notre pays
pensez vous que ce nouveau chemin soit
compatible avec le maintien de la
réforme des retraites dès cette semaine
je recevrai l'ensemble des partenaires
sociaux
mon objectif est de mettre tous les
sujets sur l'aca autre prestation
attendue celle du nouveau garde des
sceaux eric dupond moretti
bousculé par l'opposition
s'il vous plaît laissez moi monsieur le
député j'ai un sens aigu du
contradictoire et du respect de la
parole de l'autre j'aimerais que vous me
laissiez au moins exprimer
pardonnez moi on ne juge en eux le
monsieur le député je voudrais vous
répondre complètement
on ne juge pas des hommes sur des a
priori me semble-t-il
vous me jugerez sur ce que j'ai fait
quand je l'aurai fait nouveau visage
personnalités déjà connu ancien député
on complétait le testing de ce nouveau
gouvernement
stéphane peu quelle impression vous a
fait le nouveau premier ministre et son
gouvernement
c'était très curieux cette séance des
questions au gouvernement parce que on
avait un premier ministre qui a pompé
beaucoup d'air en faisant des réponses
très longue et très creuse alors c'est
pas la qualité de l'homme qui est en
cause je pense pas rentrer ce qui est en
cause c'est quand même avec lui un très
longue et très creuse
ouais ouais je crois que jean luc
mélenchon une expression produire les
arbres ont le temps de pousser entre les
mots bon c'est voilà c'était une autre
façon de dire comment et de la farm
l'ouémé mais non mais pas seulement
justement c'est pas que de la forme
c'est que si vous voulez on est dos
quand même dans un paradoxe puisque dans
une émission qui s'appelle parlement
hebdo deux parlements et encore une
énième fois abaissées par quelque chose
qui est assez peu commentée à ma grande
surprise dans la vème république le
gouvernement il est redevable devant
l'assemblée et devant le parlement
pas devant le président de la république
c'est la raison pour laquelle plusieurs
fois pendant la cinquième république
nous avons eu des cohabitations quand la
majorité de l'assemblée nationale
changer de gouvernement changé et le
président restait bon là vous avez un
président de la république qui demande à
son premier ministre nommé et à son
gouvernement de suspendre sa déclaration
de politique générale de suspendre le
vote de confiance de l'assemblée qui
normalement l'acte déclencheur de
l'action du gouvernement est de le
suspendre au discours du président de la
république qui doit avoir lieu le 14
juillet renvoyant la discussion de
politique le débat politique générale
après le 14 juillet laisse pas la
semaine prochaine et donc forcément nous
avons une situation où entre les deux
vous avez un gouvernement qui est nommé
qui ne peut rien dire que c'est un
mépris
législatif les prix du parlement bien
sûr c'est un acte supplémentaire d'une
présidentialisation du pouvoir d'une
concentration des pouvoirs dans les
mains d'un seul homme et moi au delà des
jugements qu'on peut avoir à l'endroit
où l on compte 2000 emmanuel macron je
pense que c'est une dérive de nos
institutions qui porte en germe un
affaiblissement de la demande et dans
d'autres pays
rien non plus jean castex par exemple il
a annoncé cette semaine vouloir rouvrir
le dossier des retraites
d'ailleurs n'at-il pas raison vouloir
régler la question urgente du
financement alors que le déficit plonge
à 30 milliards en 2020 ça c'était une
annonce quand même qu'il a fait cette
semaine et mais bon d'abord vous n'avez
vu le formidable accueil que lui ont
réservé les partenaires sociaux hier qui
ont été reçus un du medef à la cfdt en
passant par la cgt toutes les forces
syndicales lui dise je l'écoutais fait
absolument pas raisonnable c'est
absolument pas à l'ordre du jour ce qui
est à l'ordre du jour de notes dans
notre pays
au sortir de la crise